cdc director dr rochelle walinski joins
us now to discuss the new
mass guidance good morning to you dr
wilinski
good morning gail thanks for having me
we're glad you're here you got a lot to
sort through for us today we just heard
in david's piece of mother thanking the
cdc for more definitive guidance about
wearing masks
still others are saying what are you
doing cdc you're confusing all of us
can you just explain will you change the
rules it seems to me
when you get new information and you get
new updated information is that what has
happened here
that's exactly right so where we were in
may is we had a country that had mostly
alpha variant of this virus only one
percent of the sequenced uh
virus was delta at the time here we are
about 10 weeks later
and most of what we're sequencing now is
delta variant and delta is just a
different
uh kind of beast as we say you know it
is much more contagious we knew that
already
the thing that's important and that is
new data that we've seen just in the
last several days but corroborated
several times
is that if you are vaccinated and you
are one of those rare
breakthrough infections you actually
have the capacity to pass it to somebody
else
it's new but it's also very scary
because you used to think if you're
vaccinated you're safe
isn't it true that if more people had
been had gotten a vaccine
we wouldn't even be dealing with the
delta variant right now
you know i think it's very true to see
that the the country that is it
has so much disease right now 80 percent
of our counties with the highest amount
of disease have
the lowest amount of vaccination in this
country less than 40 percent of the
people vaccinated
so there is no doubt that the reason
that we have so much disease right now
is because it has gone after those who
are unprotected unvaccinated
and the vast majority of transmission
that is happening in this country
is happening among unvaccinated people
dr walinski where do you see this trend
going in terms of infections as we head
towards the fault tom frieden was here
uh one of your predecessors at the cdc
yesterday and he said we could have 200
000
infections daily by the fall and
do you see us having to actually up mass
guidance even further from this point
we will follow the science and we'll
have the science lead the
recommendations that we make i certainly
hope we don't have to be in that
situation but what i can tell you is
this we can halt the chain of
transmission we can do
something if we unify together if we get
people vaccinated who are
not yet vaccinated if we mask in the
interim we can halt this in just a
matter of a couple of weeks dr wolinski
the cdc also recommends that everyone in
schools
wear masks but when you look at the data
1.3 to 3.6 children have been
hospitalized because of
uh covet .26 deaths when it comes to
children so when you hear
parents say why do i need to wear or
have my child wear a mask can you
explain that
yeah several important things first of
all um
we want kids back in school we want
school to be full-time
in person we want uh children to be able
to to enjoy the school year we've seen
outbreaks this summer
of schools at summer schools that have
not been complying with the guidance and
we know that when
when you have a lot of disease around it
comes in from the community and then it
can
spread in schools if you don't do what
is necessary we also know we don't have
vaccines available yet for children
11 and younger and our children who are
12 to 17
only about 30 percent of them so far
going into the school year have been
vaccinated so we know that the majority
of children who are entering the school
year will not be vaccinated
i know people are saying that that
children do better
and they do than adults older adults
with this virus they tend to be more
asymptomatic
they tend to have fewer symptoms but i
do want to emphasize that if you compare
cova deaths to children this year
compared to flu deaths in prior years
it's about twofold more so it is really
important to understand that
while children are not getting sick
nearly at the rate as adults are they're
getting sick more than they would during
a
standard flu season and more deaths
indeed president biden is expected to
announce today or
very soon that he wants all federal
workers to get the vaccine
are you hoping that private companies i
know it's their decision
but are you hoping that private
companies will follow suit
i am hoping that we will do everything
to unify as a country to get more and
more people vaccinated and if that's one
strategy in our toolbox i'd be all for
it
thank you very much dr rachelle wolinski
we appreciate your time
thanks so much